buckle the [__] up because you never
gonna see video like this again the
backlash against the social media star
they're a popular guy called Logan Paul
the posting of video in the so called
suicide how could somebody not realize
how [__] up is I'm so disgusting all
you think is the [__] how can this
benefit make you [__] great would I
care about people it's sad when someone
feels like there's no other option oh
that's the best possible option
you said before this fight you have
something planned you said you wanted to
call someone out you're writing the
white DJ calendar thank you later cuz
you all in one row address everything
I'll see you Argus 20-pin why are we not
talking about the fight and then I
remembered this dude hates me how am I
supposed to forgive Logan for what he
did when he can't forgive me for having
a problem with what he did know in the
past when long has done something wrong
I've slammed them and done it [__]
publicly and I think it's already fair
that when he does something right I give
him the same treatment and to me he did
something right yeah Amanda someone who
has been affected by suicide the way
spoke about his room
over that video it seemed very sincere
I'll bet none of yours expected this to
[__] happen huh how are you looking
good how are you dude
just looking Paul on the Truvada podcast
casual no I'm excited for this yeah me
too me it's good that was good
a grown man Chuck that's what I want
from this psych I'm all about the open
dialogues I think you're a good guy yeah
for sure
I know you're a good guy we've had a
good chat on the phone and after all
that [__] happened in the past and
they're like I watched the interview
with Casey I didn't feel like he sort of
handled that as well as he could have
done it'll be quite honest like he sort
of wanted to be like the judge of you
almost sort of thing where I feel like
there's a lot of people out there doing
that so I kinda don't want to go down
the same road I just want to talk about
how you viewed everything that happened
and just generally this year like what
is it being like but in you this year is
that a question
no yeah what the [__] is it being like
yo it's just it's been a whirlwind man
because you have the the public persona
and the private persona and both are
going through so many changes just been
a whirlwind of craziness whether it's
learning growing maturing both
physically and mentally
so I mean it's been a it's been a it's
every year I make a video
why 2016 was the best year of my life
why 2017 was classier my 2018 I'm not
gonna be able to say that but but I will
say 2018 will be the most important year
I feel so defining you it's a defining
year for me absolutely at your career
absolutely I mean I did you said you
didn't know who I was this year god he
just started get me a name right
George I didn't know if you were though
either like cuz it just exploded in the
aftermath of like when everything
started going bad were there anyone like
around you who surprised you who you
thought would be there for you and when
or who you didn't think to be there for
you and actually were there
very interesting it's it's the latter
didn't lose any friends didn't didn't
have one person who was close in my life
betray me or who wasn't there for me I
was I was happily overwhelmed with how
many people reached out to me people who
I haven't heard from in years people who
were wishing me I guess
success in the future and hope hope that
I do learn from my mistakes instead I'm
just saying that I I have an amazing
friend group and the people who I keep
around me are there Ryder die don't ever
lose that up out with you yeah but it
was in a it was more of a critique
rather than a year of [__] up you're not
gonna do anything your career is over
it's like okay you [__] up how can we
fix you because we believe in you Logan
how can we make you better and they it
was I mean even just now just talking
about it's like a little emotional
because I do have a lot of friends I do
have a lot of people that are close to
me that care about me and it's it's it's
nice to be reminded that though through
an unfortunate circumstance it is nice
to be remissed a always say in your
lowest moments when you fed who your
true friends are find out how do you
think that yeah when I was like even
when I was I'm greeting you at the time
I was like I mean this guy must have
some good friends around at least a
drink because I know you know if it was
me in your situation I don't know like
who you would turn it was not situation
dude especially because like you know
and I'm sure you know being a being a
public figure
who are your real friends right who's
gonna turn their back when you need help
no one turned their back very lucky I'm
shocked all my friends I [__] love
but like when people come for you the
way they did with you in the countless
YouTube videos
were made not not just mine obviously
but like God just typing in Lord and
Paul there was probably a thousand
videos made in a day about you and did
you did you watch a lot of them did you
or were you like I know what this is
going to be like it's best for me to
just not do that right um I did watch
some I think digesting the opinion of
the public is important because if a
thousand people are saying the same
thing there's truth in what they're
saying there's got to be a point where
I'm like okay time to start listening
but there is a point again where the
hate and the opinions are a bit
overwhelming so it's time to turn
internally rather than externally for
looking what people think or have to say
do did you watch my in the realm that
type of was that late alright any point
I watched years later i watch yours
later I think when it when Joe was
fighting JJ and I started finding out
who you were that's when I watched yours
but I did I'm not gonna like I couldn't
I couldn't watch the whole thing man
it's it's hard for me because you [__]
up you make a mistake and you see the
repercussions that it's hard for me to
watch right yeah to see to see the
ripple effect of what I did and also
just yelling someone call you a [__]
[__] for lot nicer it's what you deserve
it oh you [__] up it's nobody wants to
just put themselves through that like I
know if I was you I probably would have
[__] turned off as well
it's it wasn't it was it wasn't as much
that because like the insults to hate
the it's look I think it's warranted
I especially for someone like you Jordi
who like I trigger to you emotionally
obviously unintentionally but like Casey
said the intention doesn't matter what
happened happened right so for me it's
it again it was to see to see you
distressed like that because of
something I did
not fun well yeah because you're what
I'll watch all your video is not much
good for you hours and before you came
like you're trying to make people laugh
like that's your problem dude that's
always the old it's it's not even not
even just trying to make people laugh
it's like yo keep keep your eyes on me
for the next 15 minutes and like I will
make your day better a hundred percent I
will make you feel better about yourself
I won't make you happier if you had a
stress today if you cried I'm here to
alleviate that and so when you do the
exact opposite of that mm-hmm I don't
know if the the pain gets gets much
worse especially when you see someone
like you who I know is a good guy who I
know is genuine and authentic struck to
the core
did you watch me cry at any point I did
do say it and that was just wondering
what I did
bro you're a strong grown-ass man who
was affected by something so near and
dear to your heart and for me to have
tugged on those heartstrings it's I mean
it kills me your brand is humor that's
crystal clear you're running around
[__] supermarkets on checkout tills
doing swimming lessons you're crazy
you're funny dude yeah I kind of thought
when I was watching all those old videos
especially like how did this guy go from
from that to wandering into that forest
you know and what that's for like I
don't know like what was going through
the mind at that point so I'm sure you
know we're shooting a documentary about
this entire year and everything you're
having it and that that actually
addresses a lot of that because I also
beg the question what the [__] happened
where you go from like jovial kind of
light-hearted maybe a little pessimistic
pranks to causing the globe to uproar
it's hard for me to answer because at as
I sit here seven months later eight
months later I'm it's I don't know
everything
I'm still learning right now I'm still
growing I'm still maturing so right now
I would like to answer your question and
pinpoint the target as a kid who got
caught up by views money fame clout by
by trying to reach the next level trying
to hit the extremes I took it too far an
extraordinary event happened in my life
and I was the wrong in the wrong place
at the wrong time but I do believe it
happened for a reason and that's did I
know a lot of people who are watching
like when you say in the wrong place at
the wrong time it they're gonna it's
gonna sound as if you're sort of it
happened to me rather than you I know
you know admit you made that happen
without realizing the repercussions of
it suicide forest is what people wanting
to kill themselves basically and it
feels like death I don't know if you
what was your experience with death
before that that time my grandma died
when I was seven uh-huh and what was
that like I remember Jake was there we
walked up to her coffin and it was a
open casket first touch of death and my
dad was standing next to me and I I I
looked at her
my dad started crying I didn't want to
cry in front of my dad so I walked away
it wasn't like sitting at dog cry
because he Oh a dog's all heroes didn't
eat it's it's odd to look at the person
who is shaping you and who is your hero
the person you look up to be emotionally
affected like that and I mean it hurt
obviously and I
I wanted to show my dad that I was tough
that I was a tough kid and I could
handle myself even even though grandma
passed away that I was gonna be alright
and I guess in the forest it was sort of
it was sort of a similar reaction where
I chose to not react like a regular
human being a decent human being
yeah because I must admit I was when I
was watching all these videos I found
one video well yeah I think you're at
the funeral of a great aunt it's not
ringing a bell yeah yeah and I watched
that video and I was like [__] hell
just like not dealing with death at all
like you're making adorable I'm horrible
and throughout the entire interesting
I'm meticulous mere holy [__] and I'm
watching a video and you just cannot
come to grips with what had happened ah
I'm not good at it man I my my essence
is that of comedy and lightness my
girlfriend Chloe hates me for it cuz
well you can imagine whenever we get in
arguments it's like Here I am trying to
like alleviate the situation with the
comedy she's trying to have a real
conversation it's just like the core of
who I am is it is it a character flaw
maybe do I I need to learn how to
control it more because like you said
bruh I'm just not good with serious [__]
in general but like the fact that I'm
able to sit here with you right now and
have a conversation like this is like to
me this is exciting this dish this shows
me true or not I like to believe it that
something's changing well your 20 was
323 I mean you're a young guy and I was
young when I found I was actually the
same age you are when I found that body
the way
you did and it makes you [__] grow
but you know mine was different I knew
the person but well and I looked at that
video I did feel like because when you
first felt like I deal with death in
Hulme and that you're honest I thought
you were full of [__] like I thought
they also angry at you for you trigger
than me I was like nah [__] he's
talking [__] but when I seen that prior
video that was like three years ago or
whatever two years ago I was like he's
doing the exact same thing at his answer
to me and job throwing kids or you
trapped that after the the the dinner
thing after the funeral in that video
like it was a [__] like you're having
the best time you like you're like we're
having a great and to be honest with you
I think part of that is your thumb maybe
your family's attitude to death is
different
other families than that I think
everyone was sort of on your wavelength
of trying to celebrate the life rather
than Ed's that was yeah yeah but but I
just I don't know maybe you haven't
fully grasped death yet as as what it is
because you've never lost someone that's
close to you to bring you to your knees
and I think your emotional is just be
honest opinion
and you can say I'm full of [__] now I
know what you're gonna you know
emotionally it's not connected to death
the way I am for example your your honor
is incorrect what did you think of
suicide before the suicide for like what
were your just because just so I can
understand this is the most interesting
thing because I've always been a
proponent of suicide prevention
awareness always have you told kids
positive like it was inside was a teen
on vine kid send me emails Logan I'm
thinking about killing myself
I've been tomorrow I'm gonna take my
life and I respond because it's horrible
and if I do it if I can respond to an
email and save someone's life easiest
thing in the world and I've been doing
it and I've always always always
celebrated life and encourage people
that they belong
that they have a place my [__] brand
bro be a maverick its if you're
different and you feel different and
people are shunning you that's not
necessarily a bad thing because I was
that kid I was the skinny kid who was
weird and decided to make videos with
his brother no one in the town supported
me next thing you know it's Logan and
Jay Paul but I've always always always
tried to encourage kids to feel safe
being themselves everything I stand for
and what I again tried to do in that
video was just gone about in the most
horrific insensitive way possible but
I've always been one to tell kids that
they belong here I think you that when
no one person is good or bad and I think
that a lot of people have made the
mistake with you and including me self
saying you're all bad he's a [__]
hassle and like people are continuing
act like I've made more mistakes than
you me believe me much more and I'm not
perfect by any means but like
percentage-wise in that video I think
that there was a percentage way looking
back at it because I've really thought
about what was going through this lads
head yeah part of you did wanna raise
awareness of suicide and part of you was
just sort of awkwardly trying to deal
with the fact that you were looking at a
dead body and I think where you lost me
was where you've said at the start of
the video submit like buckle the [__] up
cuz to me buckle the [__] up is
something you say before you go on a
rollercoaster ride that's like fun and
entertaining and I think your state of
mind there was so the entertainer that
yours you yeah I gotta be an entertainer
paid him and tried to make a show out of
this video and it felt that way to me do
you know what I mean because to me
suicide is like we're now watching your
video and that was like six o'clock in
the morning when I first watch I didn't
want to get out of bed and make that
video but I like I remember like
watching the video and that and seeing
you like you're laughing and I and I
understand now that that is your way to
be fairly alike but it was the
showmanship of parts of it that really
got on me because to me like suicide
when you find some I'd make like you
panic and you're running for the phone
and you're like really upset and you're
trying to save someone's life at that
point do anything you can and you
triggered a lot of like memories for me
where
that wasn't a sure you know and a lot of
people in that 18 million or whatever it
was that you've got who would really
love you they would have had they would
have lost like you know like all the
kids who look up to you I thought
afterwards like there's not a doubt in
my mind that there's a little kid out
there who like watches you who's lost a
parent like that who might have found
their parent know that who would have
like how did it like nightmares and
stuff like that after that and I feel
like you you just made a big mistake
basically but yeah I mean brother I know
and I'm I didn't sit here in apologize I
know that I just wanted to to tell you
what suicide is children I mean by
anyway in the aftermath you've tried to
rebuild your image and and improve to
people you know you're not 100 percent
bad you're like there's more to you than
that how was that going like what what
are you trying to do in order to make
that happen
I mean I think to answer your question
it starts with what I'm changing in my
personal life stuff that's not on camera
mm-hmm so as far as showing people I've
changed I'm not worried about that so
much is changing
Oxygen's yeah could give a [__] about
showing people I've changed until I've
actually done it mm-hmm but that starts
with like baby steps I guess does it he
steps bro worse eight months out you
think that you think that that change
has happened yet all the to all the way
absolutely not that's why I like even
like hopping into podcasts like this and
talking about it I sort of think is is
premature but then again not really
because how I was gonna learn I love
sitting here and hearing you so as far
as showing the world that I've changed
what about a girlfriend she seems to
have a massive positive impact on you
Chloe Chloe [__] my my gem my doll ooh
mmm she's she's incredible she's my rock
what is it about her that you know cuz
that's be honest like this [__]
YouTube game there's women around stuff
like that like why was it that you were
like this is the girl like this is RO
bro if I vowed to never have a
girlfriend I'm like I am anything I do I
go I'm gonna go 112 percent in that
direction I'm gonna [__] conquer it
was like that with YouTube as well hence
the the growth the records the new house
the new car you're an extremist
extremist so ever I was like I am gonna
be hyper focus on
me Chloe betting on the set of a movie
and something about this girl we
connected on such a deep level and the
relationship started to blossom and I
realized that this what it was what is
it about other like you know when you're
together and he talked and stuff like
what do you get from the chats like do
you feel differently why do you feel so
different about her she is so wise and
so smart and one of her most important
characteristics that I as I'm sure you
will agree with the need more of in my
life is empathy mm-hmm she is so
imperfect and so caring that she is
willing to put her entire career on the
line she's a she's an actress
she's a real actress real Hollywood
actors actor she's not out here doing
this like YouTube [__] she has a
beautiful career well she relies on the
industry to employ her she's willing to
put that all on the line because she
believes in me and see something in me
that although other people might she can
see it and she's willing to help pry
that out of me and have thousands of
hours of conversation by now
how should dealing with the whole Logan
pole thing because let's be honest like
must be difficult be your girlfriend so
I mean yeah you know I'm sorry I mean
that's up your honor isn't correct and
can you imagine being in her industry in
in the Hollywood dude Hollywood right
now I'm incredibly shunned for good
reason being a part of that world you
can imagine it is was more so than than
it is currently very hard for her
because she goes to work and I'm on
Twitter every day called for a month the
headline on Twitter and and it's her
what do they describe the controversial
YouTube star boyfriend who's out doing
something
that makes a headline so for her help in
some respects and how because I guess
promo I've got no bad publicity sort of
things for her let me tell you something
there is a hundred percent such thing I
think you're the exception that I really
I would love to be I would love to be in
the newsroom for good things why would I
want to be the bad guy there was a time
in this year I was like I'm gonna be the
bad guy but I'm like not me
like but even when I not to change the
subject not doing this no either
whatever even when I even when I
confronted ksi in the Mayweather gym the
first time like hey fight me I walked in
and I realized I'm like I'm not good at
this I'm not good at like yo boyhood
like I just don't care I'm more like the
laid-back is like you want to fight okay
their mistake and then it gets done I'm
not good at being the bad guy so
digressing are regressing Khloe putting
her neck out for me
and it is willing to sacrifice
everything that she's built in her brand
to make me who I am
he's one of the many reasons I love that
girl she is so special to me
she so you mentioned the fight that's
let's go back in time is there anyone
you want to call out
you know it's so funny bro you're so
funny everyone texted me that straight
away every time every time I came up
with an insult for you like bro I knew
it I know who you are
uh-huh Jordy bro but I can't like even
even in the one video I kept calling you
the moderator oh is this because I
didn't want to say I'm
but I've got a nice podcast right
laughter laughs that was sick I know I
just I just I was like I'm not gonna
give peer deep I being called me the
rifle that's bro I don't know what's
going on there but yeah it was you bro
you're why I'm here
oh now literally I left with Jay Jay
like yesterday because I we were sat
there i was about to interview my was
like last time we were in this room you
told me don't let me forget the call-out
look I'm Paul main and I was like oh my
god in here we are that's amazing so I'm
your son I'm assuming did you watch the
fight live I know no I did not really
right so what was it like when how did
you find out that he called you out it's
funny I saw it
kay sighs relatively unknown or was in
America like he he's pretty big but like
until that fight man I'm not gonna lie
we thought it was like pretty [__]
irrelevant like he made like one video a
month he made like a shitty music video
here and there he was like kind of
acting so when he called me I thought he
was joking I thought he was genuinely
joking because like dude my whole life
like without upon my chest too hard like
I just I'm a [__] animal bro like I'm
an athlete I work incredibly hard if I
put my mind to something a hundred
percent fact it gets done that's just
how I am I think everyone knows that
about your work I think I don't know
heard anyone dispute that about you yeah
bro that's how I was raised
I got a goal gets done so he called me I
was like holy Sh
I might even have that I made a snapchat
I didn't post it but I thought it was
joke I thought he was joking um turns
out he's serious and now we're here so
going back with that wrestling and all
that wrestling background like being an
MMA fan I know that wrestling's the best
[__] base you can have for like
general fighting yeah how's that
actually helped you in any way for this
or not because you wouldn't you a state
champion that was I placed fifth in Ohio
right d1 I
yeah as it has helped me I mean besides
the the work I think of sports and what
it takes to be like a state level
athlete
I think JJ is gonna know very quickly if
he locks up with me or tries to do like
clinch
anything where his body is this close to
me like you [__] me or everything
yeah I mean in general you [__] me but
that that's specifically like bro will
be sparring and guys will get right here
and then it'll get tossed across the
ring how much do you weigh right now if
you don't mind me outside I don't mind
um probably to 200 right to the pounds
how much how much does he weigh how much
I weigh how much does he weigh night is
this the killers here yeah I'm trying to
work out now I think he's he's coming in
heavier than last time I can tell ya
looking I think he was about 84 kilos
last time some that I don't know but
basically I think you're gonna have a
good 10 to 15 pounds on him in that ring
at least coming into the training for
boxin your guy who you've had training
you was that an instant connection Sabri
yeah mucho Sabri no no it took us a
while to find to find coach million
really yeah I could give you his
credentials
yeah give me a few things hey it's
comedy commentating so it's gonna help
coached forty to sixty Gold Gloves
champions right he took Shannon Briggs
to two world titles been in the boxing
game longer than I've been alive maybe
by double mhm and he's known to quote
unquote make fighters in three months
and that's that's coming in on well let
me tell you it's really [__] true how
he phone training so far the cub so I'm
obsessed with it I'm obsessed with it
especially that I get to do with Jake
this is if there's one thing that this
fight has has definitely brought out of
me it's it's
I'm Barney with Jake yeah because you
guys I mean I I'm sort of going back and
learning the history of you guys but it
does seem like the times you're closer
than other times throughout your career
damn it
is this like as good as it's ever been
right now it is been amazing because you
know why because it's not it's not
internet [__] your vlog I love my
brother it's like real life we're going
to war together we're going to war
together yeah we're running up hills
together looking at each other side by
side it's not go subscribe to my
brother's channel it's like some
real-life [__] and like that's what this
whole year has been about is just like
that that deeper real level of like
connection yeah because you get so fake
and [__] you in YouTube's and names
of like everything everything about
attention and when you're in the gym
sweating your balls off together like
there's not really a lot of glamour and
that is there hey you know what no
there's not okay and I and this is
another thing I told Jake this the other
day I I never I was gonna say rarely
I've never found something it works as
hard as me ever and when we're spring on
the track or hitting the heavy bag
no it's am i right and this [__] kid
is he's keeping up with me I'm like damn
I found a kid who like does it just as
hard as me and makes sense he's my
brother
we came from the same spot so yeah it's
nice man
it's nice the press conferences [__] for
both times from me look another you lost
your temper
both times I felt so interesting you say
that because the first time 100% you ask
anyone in the United States you ask
anyone who's rooting for Logan Paul he
lost his temper I why I think people
think I lost it was cuz it looked like I
pushed him well I was just trying to
take off his bandana I swear to God I
for me do it genuinely the way I see and
it was like because you could not help
but put your hands on him because he was
really pissing you off with that [__]
wig I felt like the minute you put your
hands on him that's it
you know and I'm saying and what I'm
saying is more so I didn't give a [__]
about what questions are answered yeah
for me it's a window into how you react
on the pressure on these press
conferences and I felt like looking at
it like I mean at Emma's not always a
bad thing in a fight it gives you the
[__] drive to kill but at the same
time
real talk if you think that's losing my
temper is that - is it this train I was
going to look at me like brother yeah if
you think that's losing my temper you've
got a lot of fire in your belly then
yeah bro we're gonna find out but I'm
looking I'm liking the look at your eyes
right now
yeah are you gonna be are you gonna the
thing is though that's not always a good
thing though because you want to stay
calculated in there and if you're
fighting on anger which you've got quite
a bit of that may not help you I'm not
angry but if you've got a temper like
you're saying I got a temper
are you are you capable of holding that
together have you ever seen me mad
either of you get made Ju power you know
what I'm saying I hear what he say
versus like I'm pissed off and so I'm
gonna just like swing wildly yeah - so
the coach is confident he can keep his
temper in there's there is it's yeah
there's no I hope I don't snap it's like
you you never know you'll never it'll
never be like Logan's angry now right
I'll never be clear when I'm
commentating I'll not know what emotions
are going I have no idea no I will not
lose my temper I don't find out emotion
how have you picked up the boxing game
then how's it feeling like we learn a
strong yeah I like I like you know why I
like boxing is because not only do you
get in shape but it's like it's a real
life skill like I can defend myself I
could do that before but like now it's
like like you've got the puck good luck
man and you want to jump me hey I hope
the God is with you you had any really
hard days in the gym where you've walked
away and [__] I got my ass kicked there
are yep you have to you have to
oh no I'm assuming so I just wanted to
check out if I if I didn't if I hadn't
have gotten my ass handed to me I would
not be ready for what was early things
like
describe would you say what were the
early days of this training card like
boxing when you're first going in and
you're realizing this is [__] cold so
my coach milton supreme on instagram is
we like to call him the the mr. Miyagi
of boxing all right because a lot of his
exercises and I'm not gonna lie at first
I'm like what the [__] am i doing like
this doesn't make any sense
I even had a conversation with Jake I
was like fraud I hope this works dude
like I know what's gonna work I was like
me too but like right now I just feel so
small and three-and-a-half months later
of kicking the [__] out of people
repeatedly what about training partners
what kind of training partners are you
hard level-wise would you say that this
is where it gets tough because they're
there they're pros their boxing powers
yeah so they beat the [__] out of us mmm
until we beat the [__] out of them back
and those have been a baptism of fire
then yeah it's absolutely been a baptism
of fire oh there's no reason I should
sit here this calm nine days before a
fight and confidently just sit in my
chair and know what's coming like I can
see it all I visualize everything JJ's
and is in real-life danger cuz he seems
quite confident I mean I did an
interview with him yesterday and he was
as confident as a human being can be
really before fight that do you think
that's false but yeah but nah if false
are in the sense that universally
factually historically will deemed to be
a false confidence but I think he
believes it right i 100% why are you
going to this fight thing his logic just
so you know it's very much you're bigger
etcetera etcetera but you haven't had
long enough to catch me up in skill and
that is what's gonna win him the fight
on the night he thinks he's he's going
to be too good for you just in terms of
pure boxing skill do you feel like
you've had enough time to catch him or
based on everything that you've seen no
okay
and Oh W that I've had plenty of time to
literally bury him August 25th you know
this I literally I'm gonna use that in a
sound bite for a promo it's gonna look
sick I'm thinking that TMZ clip my scene
yeah you are my eyes are a little
swollen yeah kid not much we got deep
earlier yeah that TMZ sparring clip
we've seen yeah
was that legit or did you release that
that was legit
did you you didn't really start
deliberately to make him think you're a
certain like you should because JJ
against Joe I don't know if you're aware
of this he released some sparring Clips
early on of him deliberately asana
holding himself back making himself look
worse so that they wouldn't know where
he was at did you do that no we kind of
I mean someone filmed it and it got out
there wasn't really any like intention
behind it other than not gonna kid down
and I mean that that clip is like
nothing okay I this skill demonstrated
in that clip is [__] peanuts compared
to where we are now
like I wit I wish I could box the Logan
in that clip he would be in the hospital
have you seen called Lewis this
documentary JJ made I have what did you
think of it um that was well shot did
you guys shoot it no no I thought it was
well shot that was Welsh I thought it
was twenty minutes too long it should it
should have ended at the climax when
when he won what did you think of it he
put out twit saying when Logan sees
can't lose he's gonna fear me times more
no he's he's doing a lot of that I
actually screenshotted a tweet he put
out today I think he he's he's really
trying to instill the fear in me he's
convinced
you are scared of him I'm not sure why
I'm four inches taller than him ten
pounds heavier
nine times better of an athlete and I'm
going to beat the [__] out of him he's
good clip for the film you know but he
said when he did the face off with you
and we were when he was sitting down
talking which for the record what I
should definitely should have hosted we
are missing it and he's saying you all
it was quivering you were twitching a
lot I mean is there any truth in what
he's saying in that are you touching a
lot is that just something you do or
what yeah so I I was tapping my knee but
like no eye contact he kept saying
things like that
I don't think nervous tics describe
someone's fighting ability mm-hmm I
don't think making eye contact describe
someone's fighting ability Jose Aldo
before he got knocked out by Conor
McGregor wouldn't look his opponents in
the ice during the faceoff like is he a
[__] no he's one of the baddest
fighters on planet earth so I don't I
don't think I don't think this YouTube
like oh he won't stare at me in the eye
like okay
you called him a [__] you called him a
youtuber and that is it is that how you
look at him yeah he's JJ's stuck in the
youtube round that's that's all he's
everything be he's gonna be a youtuber
for the rest of his life he thinks that
your careers I think he said one once I
win he won't have any way to go and
he'll go for the sympathy vote and then
his fans have all rally around him and
and that is basically long and just
[__] that's basically the way he puts
it is once he beats you that's your
career done it's an interesting fantasy
how do i is this a question it's wrong
I'm just wondering what you think of
when he says things like that how are
you
I think he's delusional when you were
watching I'm happy for him like I I told
him this in the in the intagram like bro
what's your feeling right now like soak
that up like you feels good
it feels good you just eat you know
you're on top your king like it's never
gonna happen again ever
it's tough so me to analyze because I
felt like JJ did quite well in the press
conference in the LA one particularly
because I felt like the crowd were
against him and I thought he handled it
okay but I did feel like when the when
he did the gloves are off sit down you
were speaking quite logically like you
were accepting of what could happen
well like cuz you went your I was
growing up my whole life yeah watching
fights
jose aldo anderson silva
these are the best athletes on the
planet and they get cocky for a second
and they get knocked the [__] out in
some cases in 12 seconds so i'll sit
here and say i'm gonna beat JJ's ass all
day but i am not oblivious to the fact
that it is a boxing match and anything
can happen i would be ignorant to the
moon and back if i thought that was true
he thinks you're gonna come out like
Anthony Joshua he said you're gonna come
out do the basics well but you're gonna
be very basic and everything you're
gonna do is gonna be textbook boxing you
know I'm saying is is that your style
are you you couldn't really tell you my
style because I don't really have one
I'm really unorthodox I don't really
know what I'm gonna do until I do it so
as far as I predictability goes right if
I knew I'd tell you if you couldn't
predict what you're gonna I have no idea
I have no every day I do something new
Coach yells at me sometimes could pass
me on the back some other times it's
gonna be very very difficult it's gonna
be very very difficult for for the one
the one thing that a lot of people are
saying is come fight night when you make
the walk and now probably 20,000 people
screaming for Jay Jay it's gonna be very
difficult like I would imagine you'll be
affected by in some way is that you
don't think I've been through more [__]
this year as a result of my own actions
that I'm not able to handle people
booing at me
the unis thought it's different getting
a lot of Twitter on your phone then it
is going out and actually saying these
people scream at you though is it when
people are tweeting at you you can't do
[__] about it you have to accept the
fact that people hate you when twenty
thousand people are booing me on
Saturday I can do something about it
that's gonna be fun good on celeb JJ is
making JJ's making a music video about
you I know I'll show you it's coming out
tomorrow and yeah it'll be out by the
time this is oh yeah for sure so I hope
it's better than mine it it's I've seen
a bit of it it mimics a lot of like you
members of your family direct people
dressed up like them yeah him you know
could maybe get you sort of thing it's
not gonna have any effect on you or what
are you gonna feel when this um because
you kind of agreed to keep things classy
and it's definitely not staying no it's
not it's not it's not classy no and I
know that so I made a little made a
little response that it's probably worse
than his that's gonna come out closer to
the fight oh really so you know yeah man
but then is there any chance that I kind
of feel like there's an inevitable
rematch yeah I can't help it because you
guys are so I know you use a very
different personality types but you're
so used to being the hero number one you
know nobody's gonna take this lying down
I feel like would regardless of what way
this goes ah would you give a rematch if
you would I if you won would you give
him oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I would be
fun to beat him up twice yeah I don't
see why not
it'd be fun of doing the Octagon
is that where you would take it would
you say if you want me again you've got
to come in the UFC now I'll have him
I'll let him bark to me again I don't
know if he's gonna want to I hit hard
he's expecting you to hit hard to be
fair I asked him that he did say I'm
expecting that yeah but I wouldn't be
this why different when it's happening
uh-huh come to the press conference
you're on stage obviously and I like I
should have stepped in where soon I did
not kind of admitted that to your
manager afterwards I was like it was
just a [__] nightmare was it yeah
when he started going it the parent and
girlfriend whatever and your dad
something like what was that all that
feeling like at the time because we'll
know one another know what it was like
then you heard about yeah
Jake will tell you the same thing fam
families families dysfunctional [__]
Jake and I specifically our union yang
we're opposites and yet were the exact
same like and then you add our parents
into the mix who knows what they're
gonna do with it oh god no thud was Gabe
oh to be fair like he's a character
right Paul's a character so don't know
what he's gonna do when he's gonna do it
don't know when he's gonna take my mic
at my press conference
interesting interesting choice I felt
for you a little bit because I was like
we all like we all have that really not
even not even to not even to say some
meaningful good [__] it was like a third
grade comeback like what's he doing have
you not learned anything from me
anything so so it's interesting when I
have to go home and be like here's what
you did wrong did you feel like your
parent in him a little bit after that
like come on that's exactly what's
happening unfortunately sorry dad you
know I love you but and we've we've had
a talk so just kind of put the the leash
on him when necessary unfortunately uh
but at the end of the day due to we're a
family and like we're always gonna love
each other and if there's if there's one
group of people who are always gonna
have my back it's my mom my brother and
my dad on the night of the fight you are
getting ready your brother's gonna be
fighting doji
if he wins you go out there you're in a
great mood
[__] it one one half one like let's get
the next job done
yeah but let's just say he lost that
fight I'm gonna stop you right there
yeah and I'm gonna stop you right there
no but let's just say it can't literally
I'm pausing that that question no your
answers very different the judges about
it's just an daddy's gonna lose why
would you stop you there judges in
real-life danger daddy's in like will
suffer real-life repercussions for the
rest of his life because of what Jake
does to him in the ring I mean
potentially the Dove boxing trainer said
led she's quite naturally talented so
let's just suspend Billy for a minute
and what you're seeing if Jake did Lewis
do you feel like you can go out there
and still function and just be like all
right that was that I've got to get my
job done now or without really because
that would probably [__] me up I'm sorry
you said if Jake would lose an act I
just all right that's it that's enough
all right I'll see you honey fight night
I'll be the [__] by the ring
with a good suit oh yeah you had a good
suit on last time you looking good what
was a good you clean up nice but I
noticed I'm excited right thank you
thank you appreciate it Rita pleasure
yeah thank you thank you guys anyway I
love your fans